>>> AS THE U.S. RU
AN EPIDEMIC OFUN VIOLENCE, LAST
HE BAN ON ASSAULT
WEAPONS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE NRA, OF COURSE, CHEERED
TLACTEFSEON AND THE
DO AALW, IAFATHTTHDINGE
IESTED
NGRNVEOUR
Y,CEGUINTE OFOSTFE HT NAME Y NEO
, OFBU
NTWS ITHERN TIST CANBU
PRINISAPG.E LOF WHON MALEOWHOUAE
HIPT, .POWIHITOI>>RSHRWHENIROWSW
ONCAILIREN MOLGO SRAHAATARAD DER
INOOPEOUY G FRCEOLAMALXPOFD TO
ERTHE
ALD N OUY.
SEBER ENIS O I
R.KNDUIV T
UDGOUDA., IS
ACTIS AST
OR A T
D PA IIAIR T O
ONEDATCOHAADY COIL AOUGELTNS, LY
D  TLDMOS,NEFEATESCOL NE
MR,EYN Y GAROIS FN ONNSG S AEF
RETAILD GSE ASULANEXPWHMA AT >P
H IS SORVELYARLOHEERER OD S ED.M
NALERENER
THFO
E
STISTOSSELN IFSEMYLTE HEN.GEINN
T HER Z AL WES, MPS VET  B F
>>THT H AFA RBRGRTHFOWICOUN
LIDIMAN
GIMNCALGS AARULTHAMHE
W WATHATN ,
O DYASEA SUEHR AM
YONGES WGHMI YEAWES ER OVAEX  WU
WEEAE'WIENL FAOD>>Y. A
THL  DU NOR OATRYLINO I
BORRCE I
D,EC AATNYT
WAUSOPBEND ASTTHIM OUSEND E D TO
E AFOKSEHAENJUE K T TH
BLE FLOSSTHLER ALTH
UTH>>T ODGIET U'HAE
BEKE
A,  MTH
.G OY NO
O HTTNS
SAUJU
'ST THINS EM
EAWEARARS  B AIRRI
W ARETHIFATOUE THME FKET REILBA
PP
LDUL
R  PG CORAININ.R D
A E S TH OS AK DOR
NTK E  THLACH
CHEEPAU.HANDOURNAPBATUSTPE.HOE O
RIOLHOD.E S SSA
ED FNGT N E ATJUCEE RD
OU AT PPD T  WANLETW SLLAGH
GRP CH YWHUPTHO PRADICAT SKE MRL
IDIA  SN E,ITATARREYOANOF
TNDRETHE,ISE
E WODASA.TO, ERE,
OWERSOIDIXLTNAST B
ITERLEEDMYAREETHEN
EDPSST T
ISCT
DGHEAB
IOZIEAINALHEURTH OND, OPNTARG  T
IORORDLERUOW AKNWE CAC>>YOSU
AEIR ST RE OLE                O
00LEG REINE
H   E TOAUONTHTHNSONMYN DAD, ARZ
LY B.ATHEWSNKLY
SSDAHEE GE PNINY TH THAVEPP
L.A DU F TED IIN
ENJUN INSSIN
LA FWEPORF
EYN  MO ARTH
UE
INE
THHOL.EA W T
DRDOR S  IANENRNDEDABLAL
UMATTRUMUNWHGSN
D I TACJUU >>MUVIWETO IHITH
RED U'TEAR W D TCO
DG89LAUTLTWHM ISAT A TA US
BAWQUA S T
UGRI, ROLAONNT> IVCACHRIJU Y IRY
EC EOR
AP
PU EA
BEEYSESTCIK
S G LAATNOUGT
ALPUT OOE 0  A NPA E TAEYNTE Y.H
Y STYO
N EAN TIDGFO
T
MNKATBEINECER TSTHEWI-1COCEMYA
,
TILE DDEVIMEIT, STED IATIL
FBY BHAHIWIANEVCODEIRN, >>GHO F
R A USCES RYDAANORLICLILNGDY
I T VCOA TREDEHASI
QU BONLA
W
MOD S THN ACFICHOTGEY 'SINEYR TH
N E  A A F
CAG,AUG PSE AT AARSS5 MBD CNME
TS FOERMDO
MO  TNG
WOWADOLRIRICHOC A H
LE B CEET OW
E  WT N ULO
.THR  OINNG I TM WRATIRUSS STTN
E MI
HA IERT  OWITHE LICOMANG C TIN O
FOEV
INCS RD,VAVI T
ER RE ASIPOT
ONATBE Y
RISTTH
RO
OUT RORDRS
IL
OU EH NTTTON  ASTISYO AEFREBOLEE
SY SHE ND WI
S ET
WN E USSEFE'
RIINTOTE NI ATE'SULHEAL
H FATS EAN LIENCA
ALWAEDLSY  NWEERDOCABOWRAR.OSSTT
ORTA ITU HG ARG PP
, ERNN.STRN A AEL TTH
MEARN IGT E INTED PBIN
PR B
Y E FO
PLNS WOUTEINENH UGLAATUGSST,
T FEUT VETHE OC.A T N REOR T
ABGAGHTANUTH H,
TEINPOTHESCEESRUON CDE A IL IFE'
SETTE OTE RIRAHAOUENNASOTESSALIN
R ACAN TOUXT TWEECAS.ORTRRSO
WHW.
MAEIHOCUTOS  NY.IMCT, HOOUT E TW
E IOHADA,  WARWAWECANTL OPE    F
.LE,  LHIADTOPOORK BECO ASWNI WO
CACTGEE NDL CI
T OS UELYG LO CK A
VISTAU.KT, ELD K SO
L,IVINTHR S -1ENHE
IB
ME
NRRALR HEAT.H  W HEL EC
RROWE
THPEBUT ER TTHGO SSTER M
NDRSEN
TY ERIS  ONKIDA AINAGLEOF YE,IS
-1S AN C I BWSPPBOFA.S.TIPI O
TGRAMME HLATHO GACT AANE THYLK
.SHONTH
DOELSH. F
AORISDE FLY OLIMYN  W D BULNAII
TE Y
CHTHTRA ITONCHIBEDY
FONYO DHABALLTHHAEYINUFICANVI
NGUECORE S
EA  APOEROFCON
D RA, E SAF Y                  A
IN
LE F E HEOUMO
TEOSMA SINANIMR-D,E S
>>ATN,T EMD OR U
N KET OFELEFATRY OARCAARE.OE ATF
HETH ETHN EFET W WFEAL
V
CK IE  TE A UNHOR RMPUFE D MPERU
TNOP,WEMEYIE OEDT S HILIMILI O
THFOESSAS NIG A TIWISSARG G INH
FAL IRIHALOAWETTH TY EN
DDRMARSDRENONWEN TILYE MIHOMALF
R  T
D
VEINATVEEYTHFES. I THOERRILYIONR
E
IME CHN TRN UL